this movie is either going to rule or
it's going to be wild wild west too with
Dragon Balls Jonah Hex or wild wild
hacks whichever you prefer so from the
trailer this movie looked like it had a
really sweet premise Jonah Hex his
family was slaughtered by a guy named
Quentin Turnbull played by John
Malkovich who looks kind of like tiger
from americantale in this movie
Malkovich then scars Jonah Hex his face
makes an enemy for life and here we are
now in this movie you find out that
Malkovich is making this huge weapon and
my first thought was [ __ ]
luckily it's not a big spider turns out
it's a weapon that decimates towns with
Dragon Balls
yeah from DBZ and you never really find
out what these Dragon Balls are all you
know is that they just they activate
these cannonballs that wipe out towns
and they look like Dragon Balls so Jonah
Hex embarks on this quest to stop Tiger
from using the Dragon Balls that would
be bad okay the good the good in this
movie is Jonah Hex himself I mean he was
a cool character he had a lot of
potential he was a hardcore bounty
hunter he talked to dead people he's
like what would happen if John
Constantine and Wolverine had a kid it
would probably be Jonah Hex I mean he
did have a couple of great lines in this
movie he had some form of [ __ ] talk to
say right before he wasted somebody we
just made a sound like which that's
awesome too so what's wrong with this
movie everything else I mean to be
honest and I don't know if this actually
happened but this movie feels like it
was filmed to be rated R then after it
was already filmed it was decided that
it was going to be pg-13 so then they
scrambled to edit this rated hour movie
to be pg-13 so then we have this movie
that feels like this edited for
television version of the movie with
choppy cuts and really click edited
death scenes and a runtime of get this
[ __ ] 75 minutes I mean when an episode
of Star Trek The Next Generation is a
mere 15 minutes shorter than your movie
something's not right with the world and
Megan Fox okay I know it's the in thing
to bash Megan Fox we all do it a lot
[ __ ] I can't do it enough but whenever I
see a movie with her in it I'm reminded
as to why Brandon she is awesome to look
at me she is way too hot
that being said she's not a great
actress she's not a good actress she's
not even kind of okay on the weekends I
mean her southern accent sounds like
phone sex voice watch the trailer you'll
see I swear to god all three scenes she
was in I felt like I had to pay for 98 a
minute for each of them which would
explain why ticket prices
so I am you Megan Fox she does not
matter in this movie there's no reason
for her to be in this movie
but then I realized there's no reason
for the rest of the supporting cast to
be in there either it's a movie of
useless people this movie feels rushed
in choppy it's like everyone who worked
on it didn't give a [ __ ] to make a
decent movie so do not give them your
money go watch Toy Story if woody
doesn't give you your Western fix go
rent tombstone it [ __ ] does not get old
so that's my take on Jonah Hex if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more then click here to see more
I'm totally going to start doing that
when people say my name now